-You interned at "SNL."
You got your start doing
a lot of sketch-comedy stuff
here in New York.
I did not realize you also
performed on a cruise ship.
Like, cruise ships
here in New York?
-Yeah, so, there's a boat
that goes around Manhattan
on both the rivers called
the Spirit of New York.
-Mm-hmm.
-And it's -- I think,
unbeknownst to the people
who just think they're getting,
like, a simple cruise
around Manhattan,
it's also a musical cruise.
Um, and so we'd open up
every cruise to, like,
let people know it was kind of
a musical cruise
by singing a boat-themed parody
of The Black Eyed Peas
"I Gotta Feeling."
-Uh-huh.
-And, like, you'd slowly see it
dawn in people's eyes.
Like, "Oh, no!
This is a musical cruise?!"
[ Laughter ]
"What have I done?!"
Um, and it was like -- Yeah.
Like, I can't hear that song now
without just being, like,
transplanted back to that place.
-Do you remember
the parody lyrics to it?
-I was trying to think of this.
Okay, I think this was --
Okay, this is the one part
I remember,
'cause we had choreo, too.
And keep in mind, like,
we're trying to pump people up
as they're, like, trying to get
off the boat.
'Cause they're like,
"I don't want to be
on this boat anymore."
But I think it was like...
♪♪ Tonight's the night ♪♪
♪♪ Let's live it up ♪♪
♪♪ Take off your coat ♪♪
♪♪ And rock the ♪♪
♪♪ Boat ♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I remember.
-Not good. It's not okay.
-It's -- It was fun.
There was one -- I worked there
the Fourth of July one year,
and I had two songs,
'cause the waiters --
We'd all get up and sing songs.
And we'd have, like,
boas on for no reason.
I don't know.
And sparkly vests just to be,
like, "Look at me!
Not at the skyline,
which you paid to look at."
Um, and there was one --
My song was "I'm So Excited"
by The Pointer Sisters.
And on Fourth of July,
I decided to do,
like, a Founding
Fathers-themed one.
So, I was like,
♪♪ I'm so excited ♪♪
Thomas Jefferson.
♪♪ I just can't hide it ♪♪
Ben Franklin.
It wasn't well-thought-out.
-[ Laughs ]
-But I got, um...
Yeah.
-I do think of those guys
as being really excited.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
Oh! Sick!
Yeah.
-Uh, you've had a lot
of wonderful guest stars
on your show.
-Yeah.
-Any favorites?
Any personal favorites?
-Okay, well, actually --
So, we had --
First season,
we had Dr. Phil on.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, and he plays
a figment of my character,
Rebecca's, imagination,
'cause she has some problems.
Um, and we'd written him
all this dialogue
that was, like,
him talking about, like,
"Well, the reason
that you do this
is because of your mother
and your father's abandonment."
And Dr. Phil came on,
and he was like, "I'm sorry.
I'll say whatever lines
you want, but I'm --
I can't say this [bleep]
Like, this is not what I --
I don't believe in this.
Like, I don't think you should
have an excuse
for why you act like you do."
He goes, "Can I just --
Can I say what I would say?"
And we were like,
"Let's do a take
of you just being you,
Dr. Phil."
And he looks me
dead in the eyes,
and he's like --
My character's obsessed
with a person named Josh
on the show.
He goes,
"Josh does not want you.
[ Laughter ]
He does not love you.
He will never love you.
You need to move on."
And I, like --
I almost started crying.
'Cause it was
so real and so true
and, like, so much better
than what we had had.
It was great.
But I-I had to go back
into therapy after that day.
-Yeah.
-And then we had Josh Groban on,
too, recently, who was amazing.
-He just seems like
the gamest guy.
-He's so --
We made him sing his own name.
-Yeah.
-At one point,
he literally goes,
♪♪ Like me, Josh Groban ♪♪
And I was like,
"Is that the first time
you've been made to sing
your own name?"
And he went, "No."
[ Laughter ]
That's just what people --
people just do to him.
They're like,
"You have the best voice.
Sing your name!"
"Okay. Fine."
-Uh, the show is so funny.
The songs are so funny
and also beautifully written.
But also, I do want to take
a second and talk about --
You guys really address
some serious issues.
You know, you talked about it
when you talked about Dr. Phil,
but you have a character
who has issues,
and you talk about
mental health issues
and, you know, issues like
suicide and
borderline personality disorder.
Have you found it -- like,
the writing of songs
a nice way to deal with that
on television?
Because I feel like it's stuff
that isn't talked about
that often.
-Yeah, I mean, I think
it's a nice way -- I think --
Songs are not only amazing
joke-delivery devices,
but they're also great devices
to deliver an idea, right?
'Cause songs are kind of
like musical essays.
You have your thesis statement,
which is in the form
of the chorus.
And then you have
your supporting paragraphs,
which are the verses
and the bridge.
And so, it's a great way
to distill something down
and be like, "This is what
we are trying to say."
And then, likewise,
when you're dealing with
a serious subject matter,
it's a good way to,
I don't know, get underneath it
and appeal to
everyone's sense of humor.
Because sense of humor, to me --
A lot of people say,
"Oh, it's a musical comedy show
about mental illness."
You know, "How do you joke
about mental illness?"
But to me, sense of humor
feels so emotional and personal
that laughing about dark issues
feels emotional
in a way that it doesn't if we
were just talking about them.
If that makes any sense.
-It does make sense.
And it certainly comes through
when you see it executed
on the show.
I just think you guys
do an incredible job,
and I'm so constantly
overwhelmed
by how many incredible songs
you write
over the course of the season.
So, congratulations on the show,
and thank you so much
for being back here.
It's always so good to see you.
-Thank you.